[Music]
hello I'm Dustin Kirkland product
manager at Google here at coop Con
Copenhagen and I'm joined by one of my
colleagues dancer Uli product manager
for Sto Dan every single session about
sto here is packed people falling out of
the room why is there so much excitement
about the sto project well I think that
the the people who have been adopting
kubernetes and and now if you know for
years in we've got a bunch of people who
are using it have realized that when
you're deploying lots of things in lots
of containers there's lots of
communication between those containers
and traffic into those containers and
sto helps them with that traffic when
you've got all that traffic you need to
monitor it see what's going on in your
application you need to control it where
that all the requests are going and of
course you need to secure it and and
people realize is they adopted
kubernetes that there wasn't anything in
the ecosystem that did all of those
things for them so sto they see as this
what will be the solution for all those
problems that's great so people talk
about day zero problems of standing up a
kubernetes and we help with that with
gke people talk about day one day two
problems getting those upgraded what
you're talking about is really a step
beyond that now you've got a kubernetes
how do you keep the interesting
workloads working on top of kubernetes
yeah really it's giving a bunch of the
tools that are similar to what our sres
have in operating services at Google one
of our first in fact the first customer
to go into production on sto was
Descartes Labs they run at gke and they
love the move to micro services but they
found that after they had adopted it
when things slowed down and when their
app wasn't running well they had no idea
why and they had multiple dependencies
between their services and no real way
to figure out what those were or which
ones were causing the problems so they
were an early adopter of isseo and they
instantly had a service graph to tell
them where their dependencies were but
most importantly they had the golden
metrics they could see what was going on
I could see where the high traffic was
where the latencies were so they could
solve the problems so sto must touch a
lot of different layers in kubernetes
certainly networking security may be
storage can you just talk a little bit
about how sto interacts with the rest of
kubernetes
well we're ultimately it's it's built on
top of kubernetes we run our services in
kubernetes we're depended on that in the
API server and really the kubernetes api
server is is everything that's building
on top of kubernetes is is you know
using the API server we are replacing or
offering an alternative as an ingress
Sto ingress you know featuring the Envoy
proxy which is a really really fast very
powerful proxy that a lot of people are
using and yeah we're building on top of
that great kubernetes ecosystem it's all
about the api's then I mean having good
clean well-defined api's and adhering to
those to those api's yeah and and what's
interesting about that is that is geo
itself helps to govern those API so I
think these two projects are gonna go
together really really well where do you
see it steel going next as we look out
to the next six months or so can you
give us a hint well we're you know we're
0.7 right now we are fast approaching we
hope 1.0 we've got about 10 companies
that we know of in production today and
so the code is getting there we've got
stability on our API so we're getting
ready to declare 1.0 and when we do that
I think we're gonna see a wave of
adoption and that's gonna be really
exciting we'll see the ecosystem start
to build we've got a lot of partners who
are building integrations right now so I
see you know us going from very early
adopters to more mainstream adoption and
a big ecosystem building around it and
like what's the what's the last hard
problems to solve before getting to that
proverbial one dot oh can you give us a
sense of like what's the big thorny
issues on your mind performance is an
issue we need to make sure that that
people understand exactly how much
latency will this add how much more
compute is it gonna add we've got the
API is pretty stable right now we need
to make sure it is stable at scale
although we do have you know whether
comm is running it about 400,000
requests a second so we were already
getting into pretty good production
stability there I was gonna ask you
about scale actually you you jumped one
step ahead of me here but four hundred
thousand containers all right sorry four
hundred thousand requests per second is
outstanding does this do help does this
do help stave off some of those some of
the
work that someone might have to do
otherwise without a service mesh in
place to help with that sort of
scalability of traffic what it does to
your to your scalability of traffic it
allows you to understand your system
better today too many people are scaling
pods on things like memory consumption
or CPU when in reality what you might
want to scale on is the amount of
traffic that you're getting or what your
latency czar doing and so it's actually
giving better tools to your operators to
to be able to run those systems better
gotcha so earlier today we've we've just
heard about the stack driver
announcements can you tell us about how
sto and stack driver might interact well
we already have in open source a a mixer
plug-in mixers one of the components of
sto that gathers telemetry a plug-in
today that that will send all of your
sto telemetry to stackdriver
we've got some really interesting things
and it works with that team right now
some stuff that we can't talk about but
you know they they announced this
kubernetes thing we're already working
on on the next big thing with those guys
okay last question security is on
everyone's mind how does sto help
improve the security model the policy
model around kubernetes itself it gives
everyone a standard way and an easy way
first of all easy way to get em TLS on
every call you know we believe in a
defense-in-depth strategy and even if
your perimeter is secure you should be
securing every single call so M TLS lets
you identify every single call that gets
made and that in turn lets you put an
authorization policy on it so it allows
everyone in the world to do what we do
at Google which is every single call is
strongly authenticated and authorized
it's as I said it's a defense and death
strategy that can't be beat it's really
well thought out thanks Dan appreciate
your time